un calme relatif règne désormais dans la
région du nord-est syrien un accord de
cessez-le-feu trouvé hier par la russie
et la turquie est entrée en vigueur dans
la province d'idlib
vadimir poutine s'est entretenu avec son
homologue turc recep tayyip erdogan pour
convenir de l'arrêt des combats
leur objectif mettre fin aux
affrontements meurtriers qui durait
depuis décembre et menacé de
s'intensifier
nous manifestons l'espoir que cet accord
servira de base pour une solution de
règlement dans la situation à la
situation d'idleb et réduire les
souffrances de la population civile et
de façon à résoudre la crise humanitaire
que cela permettra de revenir les
conditions à un retour à la paix pour
l'ensemble des parties impliquées dans
le conflit en syrie les deux pays se
sont entendus sur l'organisation de
patrouilles communes le long de
l'autoroute m4 un axe crucial qui
traverse la province syrienne d'idlib
qui s'est retrouvé au coeur des tensions
ces derniers mois
une première pour la russie et la
turquie dont les troupes surveilleront
semble cette zone
nous allons faire tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour aider tous ceux qui en
ont besoin un siège
en plus nous allons conditions pour que
les réfugiés puissent revenir leurs
foyers ceux qui ont dû quitter leur pays
à cause de ses attaques
mais le cessez le feu reste fragile et
redonne ainsi indiqué pouvoir répliquer
de toutes ses forces et par tous face à
d'éventuelles attaques
pour préserver cette cessation des
hostilités une réunion du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu à la demande de la
russie se tiendra à 18h ce vendredi
[Musique]